there is an aspect of ordinary that we
haven't discussed yet that is to say
this morning we heard quite correctly
about vogner creating this work as a
critique of capitalist society and I
think Michael made a very persuasive
case that there is an ecological
dimension two important aspects of this
work but we must not forget that when
vogner became a critic of capitalism and
a bourgeois life he attacked it in the
name of a certain kind of primitivism
and attacked it in the name of a cult of
unreason and proposed to put in its
place values and symbols that are may
not necessarily be the ones that we
would want to live by I mean I'm not
speaking here about the question of
vogner and Prejudice and the Jews and
all that but leaving all that aside just
you know that his his fanatical belief
in myth his fanatical belief in origins
his fanatical belief in archaism his
fanatical belief in the primitive did
this was something that you know
bourgeois society already in his time
but later in the early 20th century a
lot of German culture they all they all
went rebelled against that and what we
have to ask ourselves is when we offer a
critique of capitalist life or bourgeois
life or consumer life shouldn't we do it
rather in the name of a humane ideal of
Reason and not in the name of these
turgid little creatures wandering around
with their esoteric symbols that appeal
only to the people who can understand
them etc etc there's something dangerous
fundamentally agree but not completely I
I was also thinking when I first heard
about this conference that if I were to
think about Karin's political and
cultural crisis Wagner is the very last
person I would go to for advice what to
do to
and moreover Vagner of the ring is the
very last Vagner kind of Wagner III
would find more wisdom in Parsifal and
in almost all but not all of de
Meistersinger than in the ring I think
Wagner of the ring is the most radical
most extreme glorification of one of the
myths that have done tremendous harm in
modernity the myths of revolution and so
I this is the part where I probably
depart a little bit from from you he
wants to replace the rule of vote and
with the rule of love then we are
returning to this to this subject this
is this is the ultimate proposal the new
humans Sigfrid and and and Brunhilde are
there to replace votin to replace the
rule of of loss engraved on vote and
spare you know love is a wonderful
virtue maybe Paul is right that it is
the greatest virtue of them all but it
is not the only virtue we we need as a
virtue student one of them is called
justice and especially when you want to
think about society as a whole
laugh is probably not the virtue you
would reach for you know love is very
good in regulating or directing
relations between individuals it's
wonderful in keeping families together
but the society as a whole should not be
kept together by laughs it should be it
should be kept together by law and I
would much rather live in the in the
world ruled by vote on than the world
ruined by ruled by zigfried individual
Vagner did not stop with the ring the
ring assent in its essentials in this
ideological impact is the work of the
mid 19th century by night by 1850 1852
the ring is set it is only the music
which remains to be written I agree with
your music is tremendously important
but the ideological significance of the
ring is stopped in in 1852 but Wagner
went further something happens to him in
54 he read for the first time Chopin
however and he read it at the moment
when he for the first time stops
believing in revolution you know until
about early 54 he still hopes that there
will be your pan-european revolution
which will completely change everything
he now is disappointed and of course
shopping however comes extremely handy
as an explanation for his disappointment
he 3 creates Tristan and his older and
suddenly it turns out that this love
which he was glorifying in the ring and
which was supposed to provide the glue
for the society the basis on which to
build a new society is not something on
which you can build a society I mean the
kind of picture of love that Tristan is
present in Chris is it's an extremely
cruel diet their dramatic problematic
cruel nihilistic and so on so there is
this is of course another very great
work rising much greater than than the
ring but he is left at this point with
the question so what what will I do with
my social vision and I think the
Meistersinger is an attempt to save to
solve at something of this optimism of
the ring with the wisdom gained in the
process of writing writing Tristan and I
think he has very very important things
to say in the Meistersinger there is a
certain vision of necessity of combining
tradition with innovation he he
understands that innovation without
rooting in the tradition is completely
sterile a vanguard Esmond he understands
that tradition which is not enlivened
with innovation is sterile -
unfortunately in the last scene he
destroys it all by creating
a vision of very frightening post
political politics may be there may be
that last scene is prophetic that
unfortunately even with all the
fantastic awareness that you have going
on through Meistersinger at the end it
can all be spoiled by by totalitarian
cultural totalitarianism and maybe that
is an interesting legacy that it is
behind that terrible la scene is
actually very real particularly today so
in that respect I think it's not
necessarily you can today look at the
work in that way it's a prophetic piece
it is undoubtedly prophetic that he
likes possibility in in modern times -
thankfully not put on the works with the
original sets and the original costumes
we can have a point of view in restaging
them in speaking to an audience and and
and putting the work through a new lens
the lens of the 21st century it's
possible to cope with that scene in that
light but it depends on the production
but I think it's it's it's interesting
that that so-called accident of the last
act of nice the thing is actually so
painfully real
you